it's time for our monthly meetup looking
through the ps+ offerings for October
2018 this month we have seven games to
get our teeth into
with six playable on the ps4 all these
games will be available from the first
Tuesday of the month that's October the
second from around midday ish so if
you're ready let's do this over on the
ps4 we have the flagship games for the
month first up is Friday the 13th the
game I'm so delighted this one is here
this is an online focused asymmetric
golf fest in which one player takes
control of Jason and the other seven
players as counselors attempting to
escape the location before he catches up
with them and murders them all it's one
of my personal favorite games which is
desperately in need of more players
since the game released single-player
offline modes have been added and the
exemplary virtual cabin lets you become
a super sleuth and unveiled tons of
Easter eggs for horror fans I have tons
of content to get you ready for action
and guides on how to be the best Jason
you can and how to survive I'll link
them in just in case you're interested
Friday the 13th is currently waiting for
a court case to clear before new content
can be added but the game appearing on
PS Plus is a great sign of things to
come
the reviews are all over the place with
four out of ten from polygon and up to
75 out of 100 from PC gamer I implore
you please give it a try next up is
another multiplayer title laser League
this is either two on two or three
versus three and asks players to
eliminate the other team using laser
fields as your skill increases timing
becomes key to winning you'll start by
running around like a madman randomly
placing laser beams but in no time at
all the strategic element takes over and
it's like a chess match set in the movie
Tron many critics absolutely love this
given it 9 out of 10 but from the user
reviews on Metacritic those views are
not for all scoring at five point seven
out of ten make of that what you will
are you trying it I'd love to know we
have a few extras to look at which add
predominantly the same as last month
except for dark eclipses which gives you
a new Oscar skin and a new dynamic theme
to download over on fortnight the third
piece
Plus pack is now available with the
PlayStation Sky trails a new glider and
a pickaxe - if you're a PS Plus sub and
play fortnight it's definitely worth the
download before we jump over to the ps3
let's quickly remind you that knowledge
is power the play link title is still
here for you to download moving on on
the ps3 we have the bridge which is also
playable on the ps4 and your Vita the
bridge is a two-dimensional logic
puzzler using physics and perspective to
test your solving skills if you've ever
seen an Escher painting you'll know what
to expect as you rotate the sight lines
to perfectly line up the solution
Nintendo Life gave this game 8 out of 10
and most of the reviewers about 7 out of
10 the second ps3 title is master reboot
it's set in the memories of other people
and is basically a first-person
exploration game which lasts around
three hours the puzzles are quite basic
but the secrets and collectibles
scattered through the world helped build
and piece together the story
the puzzles range from typical pattern
understanding music recreation and
generic button pressing quests I
struggled to find review scores for
master reboot but IGN gave it 6 point 2
out of 10 back in 2014 over on the beta
we have two games that are playable on
ps4 first is rocket bird 2 evolution
this is an action shooter which is
pretty damn fun watching a chicken blow
chunks out of the enemy and rescue
comrades is unexpectedly enjoyable it's
essentially a twin stick shooter which
the Vita plays perfectly but the rocket
bird 2 visuals and loose story are also
worth your playtime and honestly it
leaves you with a smile on your face and
finally game 7 for the month is 2060 for
read only memories this is a story based
game with retro graphics a random robot
shows up at your home and sets actions
into motion which can't be stopped your
journalistic skills kick in as you talk
to countless NPCs about the events which
I won't spoil now remember it's a visual
novel so there's a great deal of reading
to do although there is quite a lot of
voice acting here but you'll still need
to pay attention to progress and
understand so there we have it 7 games
to play this month
pretty please download Friday the 13th
I'm dying to jump back in online and the
game needs real people again what are
you grabbing anyway please let us know
in the comments
from Playstation grenade it's been a
pleasure see you next time